>> ALL RIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> STOP IT, STOP IT.
>> WHAT A GORGEOUS THURSDAY IT
IS. AND NOT JUST BECAUSE PETE
EXITS THIS YEAR. HE'S SO HOT,
AOC WANTS TO BAN HIM ALONG WITH
GAS STOVES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HE'S SO HOT, HE CAN BE MY
TWIN BROTHER. YOU KNOW IT. OH, I
AM EXAGGERATING. ANYWAY, I AM
WAY HOTTER. WE ARE GOING TO
TACKLE THE WHOLE BIDEN
CLASSIFIED BIDEN SCANDAL IN
MINUTES. FIRST, LET'S DO THIS,
SHALL WE?
>> THE AUDIENCE DECIDE THE
STORY.
>> YEAH, WE ARE THE ONLY SHOW
THAT DOES THIS BUT FOR A REASON.
HERE IS A REFRESHER, I AM GOING
TO GIVER YOU TWO TOPICS AND
WHICHEVER GETS THE MOST APPLAUSE
WINS. BY THE WAY, IT IS THE SAME
WAY PETE PICKS OUT A SPEEDO.
OPEN THE DRAPES. TOPIC ONE,
BARKLEY RAISED THE U.S. GDP IN
THE FIRST QUARTER SEES A MILD
RECESSIO
RECESSION LED BY THE RISE OF CON
ASSUMPTION. ALL RIGHT, LET'S
HEAR YOUR APPLAUSE.
>> SORRY.
>> NOT JAZZ, I TAKE IT. HERE IS
THE SECOND STORY. WE GOT AN
UPDATE ON THE CANADIAN HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ CHEERS ]
>> WELL, I GUESS IT IS OUT OF MY
HANDS. IT SUCKS. IT SUCKS. WE
HAD THREE QUALIFIER EXPERTS ON
REMOTE TO EXPLAIN THE ECONOMIC
FORECAST. I FEEL KIND OF BAD,
LOOK AT HIM.
>> OH WELL. OH WELL.
>> GET LOST, NERDS. ROLL IT,
JANET.
>> IF IT HAPPENS UP THERE, WE
REPORT DOWN HERE. YOU ARE
WATCHING GAZOOMBA GATE, CANADA
2023, WEEK 17. IT IS TIME TO
COVER THE OTHER GOLDEN GLOBE.
HERE IS AS QUICK MEMORY SUMMARY.
SHE WAS ONCE A HE BEGAN
IDENTIFYING AS FEMALE AND
STARTED WEARING MASSIVE
PROSTHETIC BREASTS. YOUR TEACHER
CAN BE USED AS A DEVICE. WE ARE
TRYING TO TACKLE THIS MESSAGE
WITH SOME MEASURE AND THAT
MEASURE IS 68D. IS THIS A TRANS
TEACHER OR IS IT A PRANK THAT
GOT WAY OUT OF HAND. THIS STORY
IS GETTING BIGGER AND BOUNCIER
AND THAT IT IS. NOW, WE HAVE AN
UPDATE. THE DISTRICT SCHOOL
BOARD IN ONTARIO VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO ASK ITS EDUCATION
DIRECTOR TO DEVELOP A
PROFESSIONALISM POLICY. THAT
INCLUDES A DRESS CODE. THIS IN
RESPONSE TO THE TRANS TEACHER
WHO APPEARS TO BE IDENTIFY AS
THE GRAND TITANS. YOU THINK A
CODE WORD WOULD BE IN PLACE OR
INSTITUTED MONTHS AGO. IN
SEPTEMBER, AFTER THIS BRAVE
LITTLE SHOW DECIDED TO TACKLE A
STORY THAT BASICALLY SCARED OFF
EVERYONE ELSE. YEAH, FOX AND
FRIENDS. PUT THAT IN YOUR
OATMEAL AND SMOKE IT. WE ARE
TALKING LARGE BREASTS HERE. HOW
LARGE? WELL, THE CAST OF THE
VIEW LIKES TO STAND NEXT TO THEM
AND APPEAR THIN. WE DOGGEDLY
COVERED THIS STORY FOR MONTHS.
KNOCKERS THE SIZE OF 18-WHEELER
OUT LASTS MOST MARRIAGES. THE
LONGOVER NEW POLICY MAY END UP
WITH "BASIC INSTINCTS" WHEN IT
RUNS ON NETFLIX TV, COMPLETELY
WATERED DOWN, THEY TAKE OUT THE
GOOD
GOOD PART. ANYTH
PEOPLE TO DO SOMETHING, THEY
DON'T WANT TO DO MUST BE
OBVIOUSLY DISCRIMINATORY. EVEN A
DRESS CODE IS IMPLEMENTED FOR
NON DISCRIMINATORY REASONS, IT
WOULD BE LIKELY TO BE FOUND TO
BE DISCRIMINATORY. WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN? YOU WEIRDO. BECAUSE
OF YOU BELIEVING WE CAN LIVE ON
A PLANET THAT NOBODY GETS HURT
AND EVERYBODY HAS TO BE DECIDED
BY A COMMITTEE. IS IT SO MUCH TO
ASK THAT TEACHERS REFRAINED FROM
WEARING BREASTS SO BIG THAT
THEY'RE CONSIDERED AS THE SITE
FOR THE NEXT WINTER OLYMPICS?
WHO ARE WE DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST? LACTATING HIPPOS?
HEARING ENORMOUS PROSTHETIC
BOOBS IS A HUMAN RIGHT. WHAT
DOES IT OPEN DOORS TO? IMAGING
IT RIGHT NOW. WELL, GOOD LUCK
TEACHING TRIG WITH THAT RIG. IT
IS TIME COMMON SENSE PREVAILS.
THAT'S ALL WE REALLY WANT.
EITHER WAY THE SCHOOL BOARD IS
EXPECTING AN INTERIM REPORT NEXT
MONT
MONTH AND DRESS
MARCH. UNTIL THEN, THEY ARE NOT
GOING ANYWHERE. AS SOON AS THE
SUN RISES IN THE EAST AND SETS
IN THE WEST, WHEN IT COMES TO
GIANT BOOBS STORES, GUTFELD DOES
IT BEST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU, I DESERVE IT.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS,
HE CHECKS HIS TATTOOS FOR TYPOS.
CO-HOS
CO-HOST
OF "F
PETE.
>> SHE'S WAY TOO CREDIBLE TO BE
DOING THIS SHOW. JERRY WILLARD.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> SHE CONSIDERS RED BULL TO BE
A SEDATIVE, KAT TIMPF. AND HE'
NEVER UNDER THE WEATHER, IT IS
UNDER HIM. MY MASSIVE SIDE KICK,
HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMPION, TYRUS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> PETE, IT IS THIS THE FIRST
TIME ON THE SHOW THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT THIS? I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE EVER TALKED ABOUT IT. WE
HAVE DONE THIS TOPIC MORE THAN
ANY OTHER TOPIC AND --
>> EVERY.
>> IN THE HISTORY OF THIS SHOW
AND THE WEEKEND'S SHOW.
>> WE DID TWO SHOWS ON UKRAINE
AND WE HAVE DONE 20.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> THAT'S OUR BRAND.
>>
GREG, I TRIED FOR MONTHS TO
GET THIS STORY ON "FOX AND
FRIENDS WEEKEND," FOR MONTHS.
THEY WON'T TOUCH IT.
>> REALLY?
>> YOU CLEARLY LOVE RATINGS.
>> WE HAVE BEEN ON TOP OF THIS
LIKE ACROSS YOUR HEART BRA. WOW,
WHAT A REFERENCE.
>> LIKE A PRO.
>> THIS IS TOTALLY UNSURPRISING
WHEN YOU LIVE IN A WORLD WHERE
STANDARDS ARE NOT ALLOW,
OBJECTIVE TRUTHS IS NOT ALLOWED.
THE INCLUSION AND EQUITY
ADVISERS GET INVOLVED WHICH
MEANS EVERYTHING MUST BE
INCLUDED TO INCLUDE WEARING THAT
ON YOUR FRONT. THIS WILL NOT
WORK, HE OR SHE WILL FILE FOR
DISCRIMINATION AND THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT WILL LOSE BECAUSE
EVERYONE LOST THEIR FRIGGIN'
MIND.
R
>
P
>>
PRANK. COULD GUYS GO SKY DIVING?
>> I AM WITH YOU.
>> THIS PERSON WINS A NOBEL
PRIZE. AND THERE WILL BE A
GUEST.
>> THEY DON'T HAVE MY JOB.
JERRY, I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWING THIS CLOSELY.
>> WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING SERIOUS, DO COMPANIES
STOP HAVING DRESS CODES, LIKE IF
I CAME TO FOX AND WORE --
>> ANYTHING GOES.
>> YOU CAN'T HAVES RULES ANYMORE
TO YOUR POINT, IT DOES NOT
EXIST. DOING MY RESEARCH OF THIS
VERY TOPIC AND AS YOU KNOW, I
READ ALL THE NOTES. I KNOW HOW
TO DO THIS.
>> YES.
>> THERE WAS ONE PHRASE I COULD
NOT GET PAST. AND THAT WAS
Z-CUP. A, B, C, D, -- Z-CUP, ID
DID NOT COMPUTE FOR ME.
>> I HEAR THAT WHEN I GO TO A
COFFEE HOUSE IN FRANCE. Z-CUP.
>> I AM GLAD I FED YOU THAT.
>> THE WORSE MY JOKES ARE, THE
HAPPIER I AM. THAT'S WHY I AM
NEVER DEPRESSED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THIS IS A
REAL? THIS IS NOT A REAL TRANS
PERSON, IT IS A FETISHES. A
FETISHES INDULGE A SPECIFIC
THING.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT WHAT YOU
WEAR TO WORK. IT IS NOT ABOUT
DRESS CODE. DRESS CODE IS
SOMETHING COMPLETELY DIFFERENT,
AM I CRAZY?
>> NO, YOU ARE NOT CRAZY. YOU
ARE NUTS.
>> ALL RIGHT, KAT, ONE OF THE
THING
THINGS I ALWAYS
REALLY WANTED TO BE A WOMAN, HE
WOULD CHOOSE TO LOOK LIKE A
WOMAN, NOT A CARICATURE OF A
WOMAN. WOULD YOU AGREE WITH ME?
>> UM --
>> JUST DO IT.
>> I WANT -- OKAY, CANADA, DON'T
SUE PLEASE, THEN WE'LL HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT IT MORE. I AM VERY
DISTURBED BY SOMETHING IN THE
STORY IT SAID, AN INTERIM REPORT
IS EXPECTED NEXT MONTH.
>> YES!
>> IT IS NOT LOOKING GOOD FOR
ME.
>> HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT WE
KNOW SO LITTLE ABOUT THIS
PERSON?
>> EXACTLY.
>> ISN'T ANYBODY IN THE GREATER
TORONTO AREA, HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO
THIS PERSON? THIS DOES NOT
APPEAR TO BE A SHY PERSON.
>> NO, NO. IF YOU TAKE A PICTURE
OF HIM IN SCHOOL, YOU WILL BE
SUSPENDED. HIGH SCHOOL KIDS
CAN'T --
>> I DID KNOW AND I AM REALLY
DIALLED INTO THIS.
>> YES.
>> FOR MY JOB WHICH I NEVER
IMAGINED WHEN I WAS IN SCHOOL.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO WHILE YOU
ARE IN COLLEGE. I DIDN'T SEE
THI
THIS
IN
POSSIBLE? DOES THIS PERSON HAVE
NEIGHBORS? DOES THIS PERSON HAVE
AN OMELET AT A DINER?
>> HE CAN'T DRIVE TO WORK IN
THAT. HE CAN'T DRIVE. SO HE'S
OBVIOUSLY CHANGING IN THE
PARKING LOT.
>> THEY DO A REALLY GOOD -- THY
DO A BETTER JOB OF LOCKING DOWN
INFORMATION OF THIS CANADIAN
BOOB TEACHER THAN OUR GOVERNMENT
DO WITH CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
>> NICELY PUT.
>> OH, YOU DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABT AND YOU BRING IT HOME WITH
SOME BRILLIANT ANALYSIS.
>> BECAUSE I HAVE TO, TO GET
PAID AND HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE.
>> REMIND ME OF THE HEALTH
INSURANCE.
>> OH, I USE IT.
>> NOT ANYMORE. TYRUS, LAST WORD
TO YOU. COME ON.
>> YOU ARE A LITTLE DIRTY
P
STRUMPET.
>> YOU ARE PART OF AN SOREL. WE
FELL FOR IT. WHAT TURT L NECK IS
GOING TO COVER IT UP. THEY DON'T
HAVE THE GUTS TO SAY TAKE IT
OFF, IT IS INAPPROPRIATE FOR
SCHOOL.
>> WHAT LANGUAGE DO YOU USE IN
THE DRESS CODE?
>> YOU WEAR GIANT --
>> IF YOUR NIPPLES ARE 12 INCHES
WIDE --
>> YES.
>> UNLESS YOU HAVE A DOCTOR'S
NOTE, YOU CAN'T HAVE THEM AT
SCHOOL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOME SORT OF
MEDICAL ISSUES, 12-INCH WIDE
NIPPLES.
>> WE HAVE TO BLUR T